thank you for joining us America we're
glad you are here this is the Dave
Ramsey show open phones a triple eight
eight two five five two two five Carolyn
is with us in Houston hi Carolyn how are
you I'm doing well and you better than I
deserve what's up in your world my world
is I'm 59 and newly divorced
I received my one-half of his retirement
but I had to roll it completely over
into another we were in a five-year
program with that so they made me start
over they would not let me grandfather
it so I'm just now starting with that
money at you know untouchable my own
401k I did take out and I got those
without penalty because of divorce or
guy did the taxes course first I'm
starting over I did your nine week class
I did not attend this week eight because
I've owned and sold so many houses in
our lifetime already we did well with
those that was fine but all of that is
gone I'm basically at Ground Zero with
an income of twelve hundred and fifty ml
for spousal support which will end in a
little over a year $500 months of that
immediately goes off the top to health
insurance that's with a program who
knows what I'm going to be able to get
you know now with this mess we thought
and that was with the $2,500 deductible
I have substantial health problems so
I'm after the nine week class but my dog
who does have an envelope and had to
have a surgery and my dad gave me 1,200
and I guess maybe $1,500 and he said I
want to help you stuff your envelopes if
he thought he sees me robbing one
envelope to make a fist but I documented
all and
your producer or defect you know I
freaked out it's like what do I do with
a few hundred dollars I don't want to
touch it but envelope this code to you I
finished paying off American Express was
my last step or do I really hold it out
for hire emergency to add my envelope do
you have a thousand dollars saved yes I
do
then you put it towards your debt okay
so what you really only have that one
thousand and then I can get the
additional five thousand I'm head of my
retirement so your 401k $5,000 no that
that one is cash available Oh what is in
your 401k that you K 120 right now it's
about a hundred and twenty-six where is
that I got me huh where's that money
it's in Jackson Hewitt and that was a
horrible nightmare we're terrible okay
and you how much is in the 401k of his
that you rolled over he only ended up
with less than what I got no you took
some of his there was a five-year wait
on it right correct how much is that
that's what that's the 126 oh you said
you cashed out your 401k in a day I'm
sorry that was 30 and that's what 25 of
it and with the 25 I've paid off all of
my debts that I would I just went stupid
I did stupid for a year you paid off all
your debt with your 401k okay and then
you got a tax bill for the other five um
I can take it out with a penalty but I'd
I've been leaving it I don't want to
touch it up no no you pull down what
stop something you pulled out thirty
thousand dollars you said you put 25 on
the debt where's the other five go
that's the five that I can still have
access to without penalty right so it's
still in there yes all right
good yes okay and when can you can't
start drawing against the 120 until five
years I'm allowed a one year thirteen
thousand each time to put it so I get it
when you're looking for in a home no
life now move back with
that is 88 okay all right and your
health prevents you from working at all
yes I'm in Texas law I've filed in 14
for Social Security disability and if I
were to get a job that takes taxes out
then they say that my Social Security
claim would go away because I'm able to
work yeah but your Social Security is
not much no it would maybe be equal to
that to myself special support yeah yeah
but that would give me the advantage to
not have to be financially attached to
this person either which would be by
myself key yeah well you're not going to
be about a year anyway so you got to do
something so um I guess if you can make
if you could develop some kind of a
career even with your health challenges
that would make you more than disability
would make you then that that would be
the best route to go because anything we
can do to increase your income is going
to be very helpful and that's where I'd
like to see this move towards because
otherwise what's going to happen is
you're going to start systematically
drawing on that first that five thousand
and then drawing down on that one twenty
and that's going to be your reality
until that money's gone and then you're
going to be a real mess so I assume
you're also drawing social just you know
you're not old enough but soon you'll be
able to draw Social Security and that'll
be helpful in them in this as well so
yeah I think you're on a very very tight
budget and anything you can do to
consider income increases is going to be
good um especially if you can do it have
an event of an income increase that you
could justify doing away with a
disability because you're making so much
doing something else that that's um that
that's a good idea but I don't know if
you can do it or not I don't know what
your limitations are with the health and
so forth so yeah you've got a very very
tight budget you're going to be very
very careful and very wise with the
dollars that you do have coming in and
you know I'm going to do everything I
can if I'm in your shoes to avoid
drawing down on this stuff
now as far as rolling some of that stuff
the the Jackson Hewitt stuff or
something and getting with someone that
you feel more comfortable with you need
to do that you need to get that money
placed the old his old 401k and what's
left of yours needs to be placed with
someone that you feel comfortable with
and that has the heart of a teacher so
that you're comfortable with your
investing right now I'm not hearing that
and if you need help doing that just get
in touch with one of our smart investor
pros the way to find out who we and who
we recommend we're not in the investment
business but the way we find out who we
recommend is going to Dave Ramsey comm
click on smart Wester put your zip code
in it'll drop down a list of smart
Wester pros in your area that we
recommend and then that money will are
not that money that lists you go to one
of those little issed and they'll sit
down with you with the heart of a
teacher and help you go through this so
Wow I'm sorry you're facing this I wish
I had a magic wand to make it go away
but I'm fresh out of batteries on my
wand and it's a tough thing you're
facing mathematically without a doubt
hey guys thanks for watching if you
enjoyed this video click the subscribe
button to get the latest content and
check out these other great clips from
the show
Oh